a major controversy in the media new
reports say chris cuomo may have forced
his old boss out of cnn by exposing a
consensual relationship jeff zucker had
with the colleague the cnn chief
announcing his son resignation today
after admitting he failed to disclose
the situation it was uncovered as part
of the investigation the chris cuomo's
tenure at the network
um
greg you have strong thoughts about this
network and about some of the things how
do you feel about this day at the
network and for jeff zucker well first i
personally want to thank jeff zucker uh
for supplying this show and my show
with so much amazing content sure he
could have gotten rid of chris cuomo a
couple years ago got rid of the cricket
muncher or don lemon but he stuck by
these incompetents and filled me with so
much quality television that i i can't i
i can't begin to thank him however i
would have been fired for that out there
exactly exactly don johnson
i wanted to enjoy this story so much
but i was so naive because i thought he
was getting fired over the ratings
not over an open secret relationship
between two divorced adults uh he should
have lost it over their collusion
coverage their anti-cop narrative all
the fake news that they spewed uh the
targeting of civilians over memes stupid
stuff like that but this relationship
doesn't even register in my brain
perhaps it's a violation of some kind of
thing and human resources but it's
nothing compared to the hazardous waste
that drips out of cnn every night i mean
think about how bad he should have been
fired how when you think about how bad
cnn got under zucker it is a left-wing
station that now tucker carlson has more
democrats watching his show
this show gets more democrats watching
than cnn does we literally drank their
milkshake on their home turf that's
humiliating so this obviously is about
chris cuomo exacting revenge it was this
was this is the this is like a
relationship version of mutually assured
destruction so you know when powerful
people know things about other powerful
people and you come after me well you
just better be careful because i also
know what's in your backyard and that's
what happened this was a sure takedown
from chris cuomo which somehow makes it
a little sad for me to enjoy it because
i wanted damn him to be fired for the
crappy product that he creates because
it is a terrible awful product that's
hurt so many people i wish he had gotten
fired for that and not this i hope cnn
should start from scratch you keep
painting a turd it still smells really
bad it's a conduit for conflict click
bait
that's what it is now
i'm the magic johnson here pass goes to
you okay well so um i found out about
this at 1101 this morning after newsroom
and i said to the team after the show
everyone has to watch the five because i
could we talk about this stuff all the
time and you're right you think you
would think that there's a million
things that the board would want to get
rid of him for and maybe actually i
think there's more yeah because you
could have weathered this pr scandal
this is not as you said consenting
adults
and she's that already at a high level
it's not like the president and the
intern right okay this is the so
you have to think there must have been
something else and if you go back to
chris cuomo's statement that he wrote on
the day that he was finally let go he he
signaled something and it was along the
lines of jeff sucker doesn't know
exactly what it's going to be that
brings him down but i have something in
my back pocket and i will play it when i
need to so that seems to be what
happened here
um
i do feel
one other thing
i want people to meet and fall in love
wherever they meet
and you often meet people at work
that you have similar interests
in
right right in my life and so
yeah you know what i'm saying i just i
just feel like i think these human
resources rules are weird so he says the
the trouble he got in is that they were
supposed to disclose he was supposed to
disclose it sooner but if you're two
consenting adults you're both divorced
and you're not sure if the relationship
is going to be going anywhere and you
both have really great jobs
at what point do you know is this going
somewhere why would we talk about this
if we don't need to it seems to me a
little bit that human resources on this
front is a little overwrought see how
this ruins a great story
let's go to the jungle if they defend us
no
you know but apparently he was going at
the end of the year
so it was already an area where he was
out and you know whether it was at the
end of yeah and so whether it was if
we've had enough of this guy we don't
want anything having to do with love sex
marriage but the interesting thing is
that katie couric wrote a book and wrote
about the fact that zucker and his
family lived in an apartment right below
the woman that he ended up having the
affair with while she was married and
both of them were married and had their
own families so who knows when it all
started i don't really care but
this is something that was totally an
open secret but what i find most
fascinating about this is that you get
these people who are in positions of
power
and they think they're god and they know
they're violating the law whether it be
andrew andrew cuomo or journalistic
integrity chris cuomo or the rules and
regulations whether it's jeff zucker but
they think i'll get away with it i'm
above it i'm better than everyone else
the rules don't apply to me and that's
what i think we're seeing now we're
seeing people come down what there may
be more to the story with zucker and i'm
sure there is but these are the people
who tried to convince us that we were
all hateful fascists and in the end they
were the ones who weren't following any
of the rules
jesse
well if i'm tubing i'm thinking wow how
did i dodge a bullet here i mean i got
off easy
um he did get off easily yeah yeah yes
he did i hear there's tapes i hear cuomo
has tapes and if if zucker had just
i heard chris might have some recordings
and and if and if zucker had just fired
him and let him keep the rest of his
contract i think maybe he wouldn't have
dropped this dirt but i think he tried
to fire him with cause and claw back
some of those millions that he was owed
and that's what made him play so dirty
right now so at t just spun off cnn into
warner media so they're just like this
now and the whole company's open it's
open season on cnn
stelter doesn't have any protection
lemon has no protection acosta has no
protection you know tubin's not
protected so all their talents looking
around like oh my god i don't have
zucker here he's not going to have my
back
they have to might even have to change
the whole business model of cnn and just
go breaking news documentaries and just
cut the crap with all the opinion fake
news conspiracy garbage because that as
a business model doesn't work so it
might have someone as a takeover artist
come in and turn it around joe rogan
rogan yeah rogan should run cnn that is
god would decide that that's the perfect
spotify should buy cnn ah and then let
joe take it over exactly
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else